Magnus Carlsen checkmated Wesley so to
win the aim chess rapid it was a match
with nothing but decisive results Magnus
was well prepared using little time and
forcing Wesley into worse positions
after a few dramatic swings of the
evaluation bar Magnus clinched the first
game and that is it
the second game Magnus Unleashed a
powerful attack constricting Wesley's
pieces instead of resigning Wesley
allowed Magnus to Checkmate in one it
wasn't over yet in the third game Wesley
fought back valiantly and earned a win
in a Time scramble and Magnus is
blundered he's going to get checkmated
here surely it was 2-1 going into the
final game Magnus wasn't fixing to let
it slip playing accurately he calmly
improved his odds in the end Magnus
finished it off in style and we
that's when